imagina que nos piden el área aproximada
entre el eje x y la gráfica de f desde x
1 x igual a 10 usando la suma de riman
por la derecha con 3 subdivisiones
iguales para hacerlo nos dan una tabla
con los valores de f los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de encontrar
una aproximación para el área entre el
eje x y la gráfica que va de x igual a 1
x igual a 10
usando la suma de riman por la derecha
con tres subdivisiones iguales
resolvamos estos juntos esto es
interesante porque no nos dan una
gráfica de la función solo nos dan los
valores de la función en ciertos puntos
de esta pero verán que esto es todo lo
que necesitamos para encontrar una área
aproximada no sabemos qué tan parecida
será al área real usando estos puntos
pero podremos encontrar una aproximación
usando la suma de riman por la derecha
voy a dibujar unos ejes porque el
visualizar gráficamente facilita hacer
las sumas de riman por la derecha aunque
pueden hacerlas sin usar gráficas
vamos de x 1 x 10 es 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y
10 nos dan el valor de fx cuando x es
igual a 1 cuando x es igual a 4 cuando x
es igual a 7 y cuando x es igual a 10 y
ahora marquemos los valores de fx el
máximo que tenemos es 8 así que hagamos
ocho divisiones 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y 8 cuando
x es igual a 1 fm 1 es igual a 6 lo
dibujamos cuando x es igual a 4 f x es
igual a 8 cuando x es igual a 7 f x es
igual a 3 y cuando x es igual a 10 f x
es igual a 5 esto es todo lo que
conocemos de la función no sabemos cómo
luce podría verse algo así o podría
lucir así algo que oscila rápidamente
también podría verse algo así de
sencillo no sabemos cómo es pero aún así
podemos hacer una próxima
del área usando la suma de riman por la
derecha con tres subdivisiones iguales
como lo hacemos nos interesa el área que
va de x igual a 1 x igual a 10 vamos a
señalar claramente los límites x igual a
1 y x igual a 10 vamos a hacer tres
subdivisiones iguales aquí podemos
dibujar las caras subdivisión tiene tres
unidades de ancho
las dibujamos para hacer las sumas de
riman no necesitamos tener subdivisiones
iguales aunque es algo que vemos con
frecuencia aquí tenemos nuestras tres
subdivisiones iguales cada una de tres
unidades de ancho y la pregunta es cómo
calculamos la altura de cada una de las
subdivisiones para que sean rectángulos
aquí es donde aplicamos la suma de riman
por la derecha si nos pidieran la suma
de riman por la izquierda usaríamos el
valor de la función en el límite
izquierdo de cada subdivisión como la
altura del rectángulo y así podríamos
calcular el área de cada uno pero nos
piden usar la suma de riman por la
derecha así que usaremos el límite
derecho para encontrar la altura de los
lados
rectángulos la altura del rectángulo de
nuestra primera subdivisión es el valor
de la función cuando x es igual a 4 qué
valores
efe de 4 es 8 la altura de este primer
rectángulo es 8 de forma similar para la
segunda subdivisión para usar la suma de
riman por la derecha tenemos que usar el
valor de la función en el límite derecho
que es x igual a 7 como altura de este
segundo rectángulo
finalmente usamos el límite derecho de
la tercera subdivisión cuando x es igual
a 10 para encontrar la altura del
respectivo rectángulo
efe de 10 5 y así queda nuestra
aproximación usando la suma de riman por
la derecha con tres subdivisiones
iguales
finalmente calculamos y sumamos las
áreas de cada uno de estos rectángulos
el primer rectángulo tiene tres unidades
de base y cuantas de altura el valor de
f de 4 es 8 por lo que el área del
primer rectángulo es 3 por ocho igual a
24 unidades cuadradas cualquiera que
ésta sea en el área del segundo
rectángulo es 3 por 3 que nos da nueve
unidades cuadradas
y el área del tercer rectángulo estrés
que es la base por la altura que es f de
10 igual a 53 por 5 es 15 el área
aproximada es 24 9 + 15 915 nos da 24 24
24 es 48 y con esto encontramos lo que
nos piden simplemente usando esta tabla
de valores y nuevamente no sabemos qué
tan buena sea nuestra aproximación del
área ya que no conocemos cómo se
comporta la función quizá haya funciones
para las cuales ésta sea una muy buena
aproximación como ésta que estoy
dibujando aquí lo que nos daría una
aproximación muy buena de su área pero
quizá la función se comporta así y en
este caso nuestra aproximación al área
sería muy mala pero sin importar el caso
podemos hacer una aproximación al área
aplicando la suma de riman usando
solamente estos valores y con esto
terminamos